in movies cars get blown up and plays
they define characters or their
characters themselves sometimes they're
the center of the shot and other times
they're in the background just helping
to set the scene but where do these cars
come from
[Music]
some of them come from the auto film
Club in Staten Island New York we rent
vehicles we modify vehicles we acquire
vehicles the lucci family has been in
the car rental business for 43 years
Max's father Ralph had an auto body shop
with his brother in Brooklyn and they
got to know people with old cars they
started getting calls from different
prop masters and people in the film
industry saying oh you guys have a body
shop where you have all these older cars
I need cars for a period piece after
awhile they were acting as liaisons
between film crews and car owners
eventually they started buying cars to
keep in their own inventory as well now
they've got about a hundred ninety
vehicles available on their Lots and a
database full of car owners willing to
rent the cars they have range from
flashy polished collectibles to beat-up
Junkers whether it's your pristine
garage Queen from the 60s or 70s or your
jalopy you know your Subaru Outback
whatever it may be there's always a
character who needs a specific type of
car the way it usually works is a
production company calls with a request
for a particular type of car if the auto
film Club doesn't have the car they'll
act as the agent for someone who does or
try to find one to buy they do have the
car they'll bring it into the garage and
make sure it's running well before it
has to be on set if there needs to be a
shot where a car is having a hard break
and it stops right in front of the
principal actor or actress then we'll
inspect the vehicle check out the brakes
this is all part of getting the car
stunt ready
they might also prepare a car to burn
rubber be smashed or get flipped for the
movie this is where I leave you the auto
film Club had to find an old Jaguar and
then gut it we remove the motor and the
transmission from it made it hollow and
then
we had some people from special-effects
come in and fabricate a fake looking
motor that we put into the vehicle and
then we had to weld a pipe so that the
actors who were flipping over this real
car could use it to gain leverage and
actually flip over this old Jaguar you
might not know it but you've probably
seen some of auto film club's cars they
supplied about 14 calves for this scene
from the 2002 spider-man movie the rest
you see were added digitally in
post-production they supplied the cars
for men in black including the zap boom
van and the car that Will Smith smashes
through when he shoots the cricket gun
that one was the lucci family's car when
Max was growing up he used to get driven
to school kindergarten every single day
we called it Old Betsy Auto Film Club
has supplied cars for Gotham the
Americans Jessica Jones and the list
goes on you can never say no to a
potential client because you never know
when they're gonna call you back
he told me to call this person who told
me to call that guy who knows a guy in
Wyoming I finally called someone and I
said do you have a 1993 to 97 Prevot bus
hatch and he said yeah I got one right
in my yard